Jim Abbott here in the Rich Eisen show
how you been Jim hey I'm great rich I
appreciate the memory and go blue go
blue right back at you do you remember
that day Jim a lot of member a lot of
days at great Fisher Stadium and playing
for Michigan it was one of the dreams
come true for me I grew up in Flint
Michigan and you know to go there and
play there it gave me so many
opportunities going forward I will
always cherish being affiliated with the
University of Michigan but I do remember
but MIT all the manager wanted to have
you bat in front of the National League
Scouts that day to show that you could
actually do it is that something that
you were battling if you will with when
you were being scouted for being drafted
in Major League Baseball Jim yeah I
think there were some questions about
whether or not I would be a fit yeah I
always thought I was a much better
hitter than I was I fancied myself a
pretty good hitter growing up and Flint
always bugged but I always told him that
you know I could help him help the
lineup and so he gave me he did give me
a couple showcase at-bats a chance to
prove myself but you know that curve
ball that changes everything is a
different than a little bit different
than growing up and flip yeah I'm sure
it's better it's easier for you to throw
it than to hit it so let's let's get
into whoa what did you think of she came
Gryphon when you watched him work out at
the combine Jim well I was I was blown
away rich I saw him I was actually
watching the the Michigan game against
UCF last year at the big house and and I
was watching and all of a sudden they
showed she team did a little piece on
him and I didn't even notice that he was
out there playing with one hand after
that I've been following him and in
rooting for him and just couldn't be
more impressed with his determination
and his toughness and I'm just so happy
that he did so well at the combine and I
hope he gets a shot to play some
professional football now he's the
reason why you're born without a right
hand the same reason why he was born
without a left Jim it's similar I didn't
I didn't done I didn't have amniotic
band syndrome I I had actually it was a
blood circulation actually lack of blood
Jason that got to the right to my right
side of my body and cause my right hand
not to develop fully so a little bit
different but almost the exact same
condition in the end and so what would
you say to him if if you could reach out
to him ah I'm assuming you have not
connected yet Jim I have not I have a
number to try to reach him and I'm
looking forward to doing that I know the
whole world is is watching I'm sure his
schedule is crazy but I just like to
tell him you know how proud I am of him
I know he's trying to be the best
possible football player he could be and
that's what he should do at this point
you know go after this dream and there's
so many people that'll be inspired by
him there's so many parents that will
look to him there's so many kids around
the country who have similar conditions
who will grasp onto his being a role
model but for now be the best football
player you can be you know go out there
live this dream give it everything you
have and and just by doing that he's
gonna provide such an incredible
inspiration to so many people and and I
just love to let him know how many
people are rooting for Jim Abbott here
on the Rich Eisen show he said Jim at
the combine when he was in front of the
media that anytime he drops a football
he knows people who think it's because
he doesn't have a left hand whereas any
other linebacker drops it it's just
assumed that it was a bad football
thrown in their direction it was just
tough to catch I'm wondering how you
would take that and try and decipher it
based on your experiences well I
remember you try to shore up weaknesses
or whatever anybody might perceive as a
weakness you know either as the
competition I really worked on my bunt
defense I really worked on the comeback
errs back up through the mom because I
you know those come back errs are tough
for any pitcher but I didn't want it you
know any sort of blame or Cydney any
sort of attention to be paid for the
idea that you know I played differently
but I had to switch the glove on and off
of my left hand and and and while that
may have been a legitimate excuse to
some degree I did not want that
perception and I'm sure he feels the
same way and you know watching his
40-yard dash
I thought it was a lot more impressive
than yours to tell you the truth I'm an
agreement Jim but gosh maybe I'm reading
into it but there was just a desire you
can just see that there is a passion
within him to you know to show people
what exactly he can do and a great
belief and his skills and I think that's
gonna serve him well well to me what
what was so special about that 438 Jim
is that it came after his 20 reps of 225
in the weight and reps room with a
prosthetic on his left hand and the
whole world saw that and in the world of
social media where you could find out in
real time on your phone what people are
saying and feel about you and it can go
to your head and he could have sat there
and thought to himself well I've made my
point he went ahead when everybody
watching him stepped on the line and not
only met expectations or hopes let's put
it that way not only met hopes he
surpassed it and to me that shows
something special about him I totally
agree and and you know I watched that
several times on social media just like
you said I replayed it and and you can
see him take a little bit extra time as
he set himself up before bursting out of
the blocks and man oh man he just
exploded and you know it reminds me a
little bit of kind of when I was growing
up I remember having some success in
locally and in Flint and then getting
the opportunity at the University of
Michigan and playing and having some
success there but you you don't really
know how you're gonna measure up you
know how am I gonna measure up against
the next level you know the best of the
best and and and his story seems to be
the same you know he had some great
success growing up he has the
athleticism and and UCF obviously had
such a great year last year and all of a
sudden boom he's going up against you
know the very best you know prospects in
United States and to show out that well
and and to do to be that impressive you
know it's one of the coolest things I've
seen in a long time Jim
here on the Rich Eisen show a couple
more minutes Jim I got to point out I
noticed it's the 25th anniversary of
your no-hitter coming up in September 25
that's unbelievable
what does it mean what is it how does
that hit you you know it means a lot to
me a no-hitter is such a cool thing and
it kind of comes out of the blue and
there's some luck involved everybody
knows that you have some balls fear that
people and your defense makes great
plays but you know which I wanted to be
remembered for being good and not just
making it but but being good and I felt
like if there was you know something to
be said for being a role model that
would go a long way towards doing that
you know that kids could aspire to not
only make it not only to participate but
you know to make a difference and to be
a contributor and while it was only one
game you know that no-hitter is you know
giving me something to hang my head on
it's given people something that
remember me by just particularly the
fact that happened in New York with the
pinstripes and with the Yankees you know
it just it's something that's been a
lifelong touchstone and something I'm
very proud of so as you mentioned every
no hitter does as you say have the the
aspect of luck what was the one I don't
remember it off the top of my head I do
remember just celebrating being a
Michigan graduate a new Yankee fan just
for me seeing you do that after I as I
mentioned being in very Fischer stadium
at day in Ann Arbor seeing you at the
collegiate level and since seeing you do
that in the Bronx in the old Yankee
Stadium it just meant so much to me
personally but was there was there a
defensive play that saved it and what
what what about that day do you remember
oh gosh there were so many great plays I
remember you know it wasn't a perfect
game I walked a few guys that day and I
had a guy on first base and Manny
Ramirez had just been called up to the
Indians that day or a couple days before
had a huge contingent from New York City
where he had a lot of friends and family
they were all down the left-field line
cheering and screaming and I didn't know
much about him there wasn't much of a
scouting report of this young kid we all
know he was good and he hit a ball at
Randy Velarde at shortstop that I don't
know how Randy got in front of it
but he did but he did it one hopped him
he kind of jumped up almost caught it in
his chest and then threw it over to
actually got a double play out of it so
I mean it was just kind of meant to be
that day and you know it's just
something like I said I cherish so much
to have that connection with the Yankee
organization and with the city well I'm
just glad that Manny ramírez career as a
Yankee killer started on September 5th
not September 4th 1993 because Manny
would have days against the Yankees no
no question about it being from right
there as you mentioned did anybody try
to bunt on you that day your call you
know funny enough a Kenny Lofton tried
to bunt 9th inning leadoff hitter for
nothing we're winning and Kenny came up
and you know obviously he was he was
tough to get out in the first place but
he took us by complete surprise tried to
bunt the ball went down the third base
line and thank goodness it trickled foul
because he would have been safe by 30
feet and I love it because the fans
rained out on Kenny pretty good at that
point the Bronx is that be Kenny swing
the bat he said Oh Jim woody what's the
unwritten rule there do you think you
know I don't know I that was a big part
of his game it was a still a close
ballgame it you know it I don't really
hold it against him in any way just but
I sure would have hated to lose a
no-hitter like that and you know that
but that's baseball that's competition
you put yourself out there and you know
thankfully it trickled foul well Jim
thanks for the call please if you're in
the Los Angeles area ever I would love
to have you here in studio and just
reminisce some more and just again thank
you for representing Michigan our
country Team USA and the human race as
you do Jim thank you well I sure
appreciate that rich right back at you
and always a pleasure
you bet that's the Jim Abbott the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience